hey what's going on everybody i'm dave
rubin it's the reuben report direct
message on today november 18th 2021 i am
in a great mood
just got some great news and i'll have
more to report to you on this greatness
in the not-too-distant future a lot of
good stuff happening remember this
moment because it's a good one it's a
good one that's all i can say right now
we are live streaming on rumble
on youtube for as long as they allow us
and on blaze tv and today we are doing a
live q a we got a couple dozen questions
from the reubenreport.locals
community if you would like to submit a
question over the course of the next
half hour and possibly get me to read it
live on the show you go to
reubenreport.locals.com the top pinned
post just put your question or comment
right in there and maybe it will get to
me you never know uh obviously guys the
big stuff going on right now is that the
kyle rittenhouse decision is likely
coming today uh there's a lot of
craziness going on in the courtroom the
judge
just barred msnbc from the courthouse
because apparently they sent a producer
that followed the jurors after they
closed up shop yesterday and people were
leaving and they followed the juror van
or something i mean really really crazy
stuff this this whole trial uh between
some of the stuff that the prosecution
has done the way the media has covered
it the whole thing has been absolutely
crazy uh suffice to say since we don't
have a decision right now i'm not going
to comment and comment on it any further
today
obviously tomorrow we're doing our
weekly roundup we'll hopefully have a
decision by then and
god willing there won't be utter chaos
all over
uh wisconsin and hopefully uh you know
the rest of the country will we shall
see but anyway we'll comment more about
it then uh but before i get to the q a
uh i did want to do one story because
bill maher who i often talk about and
bill maher i would say has been the
standard bearer of the left of
liberalism in america for almost three
decades now i mean the guy's been doing
it for a long time people think of real
time with bill maher which has been on
for about 20 years or so
but he had a show on abc before that
called politically incorrect that was a
round table comedians and political
people and pundits and journalists
arguing about politics he had that show
for about 10 years before that it got
cancelled right after 9 11 after he said
some stuff so he's been through cancel
culture anyway bill maher i would say is
an old school liberal
who suddenly does seem to be getting red
pilled and what i've been trying to get
bill to do because i know a lot of the
producers watch this show what i've been
trying to show them is that bill just
needs to kind of take that last final
step well in any event bill was on chris
cuomo's show on cnn last night and he
was making a whole lot of sense um but
can he get to the end conclusion
that's the question here's a clip from
last night a quick question
woke
the response from the people that you
put it on will say
no
woke is aware
and inclusive and there is no canceled
culture it's just accountability these
are not bad things they are good things
disagree
well woke yes i mean i i don't remember
the day the term was born uh although i
i hear uh aoc says only old people use
it now
well you gave it to us
like five years ago so sorry we didn't
get the memo
right away you know that's such a high
school thing we're not using that
anymore
we all wear pink on wednesdays okay you
whatever term you want uh i don't care
uh again i just got used to this one and
yes in its best sense if we're talking
about um being aware of things that we
always should have been aware of more
reckonings that we've had with
sexual malpheasants with racial
injustice that's all a good thing but
there's a reason why the term woke has
come to
signify
going too far
and doing things that don't make sense i
keep saying this to the democratic party
the reason why you're so toxic is
because you have become the party of no
common sense
and people see this on their news feeds
i mean you were saying to me in the
break people mostly go on with their
lives they do but they see things on
their phone or on their facebook page
people pass things around and it's a
constant drip drip drip of oh these
people are nuts
all right bill maher i want to give
credit where credit is due yes you are
right the democratic party has become
the party of no common sense you are an
outsider in your own party and by the
way i think it's quite a lofty goal
for people to fight for their true
principles within
their own party right for many many
years i still considered myself
on the left and i was a liberal on the
left saying hey you wokesters and
progressives you're you guys are out of
control but they just kept coming and
coming and they've destroyed the party i
mean show me a democrat politician
please i ask for this all the time and i
i don't mean it sarcastically actually
show me a democrat politician who bill
maher could vote for that vote for that
is actively trying to stop wokeness that
is against identity politics uh you
might say well there's one there's tulsi
gabbard except the democrats basically
hate her at this point i like her a lot
i think she's a decent liberal i suspect
we disagree on some stuff but i know
that we both love this country but there
is virtually no
active influential democrat politician
uh that is doing any of the things that
bill mark cares about so you know a
couple weeks ago right before the
virginia election bill maher was ranting
and raving rightly so about how evil
critical race theory is and they're
turning this on the parents and domestic
spying as if the parents are terrorists
and all of this stuff um but he didn't
really tell people to vote for glenn
younkin and then when glen younkin won i
don't know that bill maher
did his show the following week i didn't
see all of it but i don't think he got
up there and said yeah you should have
supported glen yunken and this is a
great
strike against the bad guys because he
thinks of himself as a good lefty
democrat and there's a there's sort of
like a self-hostage situation happening
with the last remaining liberals and i
would you know add a couple people i
don't mean to make this about people but
i would talk about the barry weiss as
the sam harris as the stephen pinkers of
the world i'm not these are not bad
people they are trying to do something
but the flaw perhaps is simply in
liberalism
itself and it pains me to say that as a
guy that wrote where is it with shoulder
that's the right shoulder there's a book
back there there's a couple copies over
there an entire defense of classical
liberalism
but none of those ideas have anything to
do with the modern democratic party
believe it or not those ideas have much
more to do with the modern republican
party and i don't consider myself a
republican you don't have to be a
republican you just cannot be a democrat
if you believe that america's founding
was good if you believe in logic and
reason and law and you believe in
individual rights i mean what does bill
maher want to do bill maher wants to
smoke pot okay most republicans don't
care about smoke and pot leave it to the
states no big deal he doesn't want this
neo-racism of the left well republicans
are fighting that all the time virtually
everywhere democrats are ushering it in
now i suppose one of the things i get
there are sort of two things i guess
that really get the liberals to be
afraid really afraid of leaving the left
one is abortion they seem to really
really love abortion um so i get it he
doesn't want to say he's a republican
because he's definitely for abortion and
then i think there's something with a
lot of them that's still very confused
about the welfare state that still we
should take money from some people and
give it to other people and i would just
say maybe bill maher needs to just read
a thomas soul book or have larry elder
back on his show uh to to finally take
the the red pill on that um but in
essence if you are a moderate liberal at
this point if you believe
that
anything that jfk stood for then you are
no longer a democrat so it's great that
bill maher is saying what conservatives
have said right it's great that bill
maher's saying all these things five
years too late but if at the end
conclusion
it's always oh but the republicans are
somehow still racist or crazy trumpists
and insurrectionists and you're going to
make all of those jokes as he still does
and those are the real bad guys and on
top of it they're
believers right they're religious morons
right that's obviously not what i think
but that's clearly what he thinks then
that's gonna be the one thing that stops
him from going all the way then he's
gonna in essence yeah he'll call out the
things that will be fine in his circles
to call out in hollywood but will not
get people to make the final conclusion
which is we must vote out all of these
people we must get rid of the ridiculous
aoc's that he talked about there get rid
of them by the ballot box you know let
her go back to being a bartender she'd
be much better at that i don't even know
that she was a good bartender i suspect
she probably wasn't but like
she'd be better at that than whatever
the hell it is she's doing now so anyway
i thought this was worth it because it's
like bill maher if you're watching this
or the producers if you're watching this
you know and i know you guys watched um
like kind of shift make the shift you'll
be okay bill you got a lot of dough you
won't be hated by everybody there's a
lot of closet conservatives in hollywood
everything's gonna be all right anyway
we're gonna get to the q a in just a sec
but i want to talk to you guys about
start mail you know free email services
like gmail and yahoo aren't really free
you pay with your privacy internet
giants bank on bank on exploiting your
data by selling it to the highest bidder
your business plan google has it your
medical records yahoo can sell them to
drug companies personally i don't want
to open myself up to identity theft and
i can't imagine you do either that's why
i suggest using start mail it makes
email feel safe again start mail keeps
email private period when you delete an
email in start mail it's gone forever
and start mail uses their own servers
not amazon's which means they can't be
put out of business like parlor
switching to start mail is seamless too
you can easily transfer all your current
email data so there's no starting from
scratch you get unlimited anonymous
aliases this feature protects your main
email address from spam and phishing
attacks so that people can't sell you in
sell your info and they can be deleted
at any time i keep saying the way to the
way forward is to build competitive
businesses that support our privacy
values which is why i value the service
that start mail provides your cyber
security has never been more at risk
take control of your privacy with start
mail before it's too late start securing
your email privacy with start mail sign
up today and you'll get 50 off your
first year go to
startmail.comruben that's start with the
t s-t-a-r-t mail.com rubin for 50 off
your first year start mail.com
reuben and now back to me i just want to
say one more time i just got some great
news and there's a lot of good things
happening in the world people can you
feel it can you feel it all right
reubenreport.locals.com if you want to
submit some more questions while we are
live let's try to get one or two live
ones in if possible storm says are you
worried that the supreme court will deem
the vaccine mandates constitutional okay
first let's go with the good news here
which we talked about on the show
yesterday
there is currently a pause on this osha
mandate that was forcing companies with
more than 100 employees to vaccinate all
of their workers okay that this is a
great bit of news uh the lawsuit was led
by the daily wire so uh
little applause to jeremy boring and ben
shapiro and the guys over there they
fought it they have over 100 employees
they were not going to force their
employees to be vaccinated or be
injected with anything that the
government just wanted them to be
injected with they've got a lot of young
healthy people working over there and
they were letting people make decisions
for themselves so that vaccine mandate
for the companies themselves has been
paused so if you work at a company and
you're there's over 100 employees there
and your company is now forcing you to
do that you are now you should go to
your hr people and say it is no longer
a mandate from the government now the
company might say hey we're going to do
it anyway and i think that a lot of
companies will because everyone's just
so caught up in all this craziness but
it is no
longer mandated by the government it's
now in the courts and until the court
decision is made it it is not valid it
is not legit so great job on the lawsuit
by the way harmeet dillon who i've had
on the show before who's a fantastic
lawyer she's brought lawsuits against
google that she is one she is a friend
and i've asked her for plenty of legal
advice that i've referenced on this show
uh she's on the show tomorrow am i am i
right about that she is on the show
tomorrow she is the lead lawyer on the
case um so am i worried that the supreme
court will deem the vaccine mandates
constitutional
right now we've got the courts meaning
that the courts seem to be less
politically active and are trying to do
things that are by the letter of the law
which is what the whole freaking
judicial branch is supposed to do so i'm
i'm somewhat confident
that the courts will not force what i
would view in many legal experts i've
read a bunch of briefs on this view as
widely
unconstitutional right to for have a
company force you to make a medical
decision there's many many many
violations their right to privacy and
health and all of these things
so my hope would be uh that they will
not
do this but uh but we shall see like
everything's in flux right now
everything's in flux patrick says
do you think the metaverse and its
possible global takeover will be a net
positive or net negative on human
civilization so if you don't know about
the metaverse this is uh what facebook
is trying to push us all into right now
you probably saw the video we played it
uh this is where you're basically gonna
wear a vr helmet like an oculus helmet
all day long and you'll have all your
meetings and you're gonna be in a zoom
meeting with all the people you work
with and you're gonna be talking to a
monkey and a lizard and a wizard and a
whole bunch of weird things and then you
know you're going to just live in this
virtual planet if you don't know exactly
what i'm talking about i would recommend
watching uh ready player one and then
watch the matrix it's some combination
of those two things
look the idea that anyone that anyone
knowing what we know now about the
internet about big tech
about the people that are running these
platforms the idea that you would follow
mark zuckerberg who i am fairly certain
is not a human and there was that video
we should have played remember that
video a while back when he was like i am
not a human i mean i am a human like the
guy i don't know what's going on there
okay but the idea that you would follow
mark zuckerberg into an alternate
reality is very very bizarre like it
just seems so weird and in some ways
this is why they've tried to destroy the
real world they've tried to make us all
so depressed and locked in our houses
and put masks on and fearful because the
best place you could ever control us is
in a world that's completely digital
that you would be able to control
everything about that world and it would
and we would just sit there with our
masks on eating gruel out of a bucket
with probably something strapped onto
our nuts like the whole thing is just
like like that's where it's all going
that's where it's all going people um so
i i don't think it will be good i think
some people will do it i think there
will be some value in it i'm not against
technology i mean that's the thing it's
like fire does good right it can heat
your home and it can also burn you like
so that's sort of what technology is
like could there be really cool things
that we could do in the metaverse could
doctors somehow be able to operate
on patients that were half the world
away because they could see in a virtual
reality world possibly could there be
very cool things related to video games
and interactive movies and all these
things sure but should we be living in
this universe this is literally what
ready player won the book and then the
movie is about and without well i can i
give i mean the movie came out years ago
if you i'm just going to give you a
little bit of the ending right now in
two sentences so if you haven't seen the
movie and you're going to see it maybe
mute for just two sentences but in
essence at the end of the movie now's
your chance to mute at the end of the
movie they realize oh we should shut
this thing down for two days a week
because it's too addictive it's too all
encompassing and we shouldn't be living
in a digital world that this world that
we're all in right now it ain't that bad
it ain't that bad despite what they're
trying to do to it kathy says how do you
celebrate thanksgiving what's your
favorite thanksgiving food so i love
thanksgiving i think it is just it's the
because it's the great american holiday
it is it is a holiday for all americans
doesn't matter where you come from what
you believe in
who you are what you look like it's our
chance once a year to say thank you to
this great country thank you for the
goodness and the food on our plate and
the people we're sitting with and
everything else so thanksgiving is the
one holiday that we host here
so we get all the david's family here
and david's an incredible
chef as i've told you guys many times
and many people in his family's mom and
his brother and his sister they're all
great chefs so we eat spectacular food i
i will definitely post some pictures um
what's my favorite thanksgiving food i
mean he does make an awesome turkey like
the skin's just freaking right um but
you like a good stuffing there's nothing
better than a good stuffing like nothing
better if you do a stuffing
right like one year david's
sister-in-law did like uh it was like a
garlic challah stuffing from mahala that
we had the night before just absolutely
incredible i love thanksgiving and i
hope you do too and by the way i just
taped an interview with melanie
kirkpatrick melanie kirkpatrick uh who
has done a really wonderful video on
prageru about the origins and the
meaning of thanksgiving it's it's a
shorter interview it's about 25 minutes
and we're going to play that during
thanksgiving week so that we're not
going hyper political that week and that
you could just learn a little bit more
about the story of thanksgiving how it
actually became a holiday how it began
and it wasn't because the pilgrims were
slaughtering the native americans
actually they were kind of doing the
holiday together a lot of interesting
stuff so we'll put that up i believe the
monday before thanksgiving uh danielle
says should the republicans make it part
of their platform to reduce or even
abolish altogether the administrative
bureaucracies like the fbi cdc nih etc
they clearly have turned on us and no
longer are honorable
agencies if they ever were
you know it's a great question it's one
of those things like these these giant
organizations that we have these giant
institutions the department of education
it's like is this thing really doing
anything good or anymore
or would you rather that your children's
education
be dealt with by the people in your
local community so you have a little
more ability to understand what your
kids are learning what ages they're
learning age-appropriate things et
cetera et cetera like i think most of us
realize that this giant top-down thing
doesn't really work as for the nih and
the cdc specifically it's like they have
completely in my view just blown their
trust right like if you go back and i'm
sure if you go back to videos that i was
doing at the beginning of kovid you know
it's like we were all trying to trust
them
i'm sure
that virtually everybody i don't think
that there were a ton of people i don't
really remember them that right from
beat one of all of this when lockdowns
were just starting in mass there weren't
a ton of people that were like screw the
nih and screw the cdc and about cheese
evil and everything we all kind of did
it whatever we were told to do i
remember going to whole foods and i'd
come home and i'd be wearing plastic
gloves and a mask on my face and david
would be wiping down paper bags like we
all did all of the stuff but over time
they consistently move the goal posts
which again is why we never talk about
two weeks to flatten the curve we
virtually never talk about herd immunity
or natural immunity they changed all of
the things that we used to know about
immunity against a virus and now it's oh
get your
uh vaccine get the second shot get a
booster oh now two boosters they're
already thinking about a fourth booster
in israel like it's crazy
lunatic nonsense and these people trot
out and fouchy comes out there every
week saying the reverse of what he said
the week before he never gives numbers
right he always gives these amorphous
statements oh when the
when the numbers go down to a tolerable
level what is that number
they never want to give you that stuff
on top of the fact that the nih was
funding the mrna research in wuhan we
now know that and was there a lab leak
like it looks like there was like
there's so much craziness here so i just
don't think these big things work
anymore i'm not saying that we shouldn't
have any organizations that are designed
to you know deal with public health but
the way that they have not only
mismanaged it but then been dishonest
about the information and that nobody
seems to care about the regular people
why isn't there anyone from the cdc
that's out there going you know we don't
really want to have to keep telling you
all of these things and we don't really
want to have you wearing masks and we do
feel bad and we do recognize that more
people are um
dying of suicide and more people are
depressed now and more people are
alcoholics like we need to also talk
about those things but they don't do any
of that that has a little something to
do with health doesn't it so yeah we
need less
top-down things and more bottom-up
things uh talia says i live in oklahoma
i have my whole life and i love it here
over the last couple days i'm seeing
more and more about the oklahoma
national guard refusing the vaccine
mandate and are now being threatened
what do you think we can expect from
this i want it to be a good thing well
first off
i mean you know my feelings about this
if the if the fine men and women who are
in the oklahoma national guard do not
want to get vaccinated
i have no problem with that they are
most likely young and healthy i am sure
there has been no massive outbreak with
a crazy amount of deaths in the oklahoma
national guard the media would prefer
you to think that everyone that isn't
vaccinated automatically has coveted
automatically killing people that is
just complete nonsense so i love it when
a group of people band together and say
hey we are going to stand up for what we
believe in that's the only way we win
this thing right um now it sounds like
the federal government is not happy
about this and they may punish oklahoma
in some way but this is where i would
say the red states primarily
but any state that wants to remain free
as a state and be able to make choices
for itself and that's not really the
blue states unfortunately any state that
wants to remain free
is going to have to figure out what does
their national guard do and maybe it's
going to have to be a little bit more
than we thought like maybe florida and
texas and tennessee and oklahoma maybe
some of these states are going to have
to start having
national guards that are going to have
to push against the federal government a
little bit i don't know exactly what
that means and i'm not saying these
people should be shooting at each other
but at some point the blue machine the
federal machine is going to keep
encroaching on the people who are trying
to live free
so we need strong
national guards in all of these states
and and i wish these guys a lot of luck
tallway says first the dogs now fauci's
uh an nia id funding island of monkeys
in south carolina used for horrific
maximum pain experiments that sounds
like a headline uh why in the name of
heaven is the left supposedly the
champion of animal rights still
listening to this guy and how much more
is it going to take to get this guy on
the charges he's earned right so now
okay so there's been some weird monkey
experiments we talked about the dog
stuff that he did i mean really crazy
stuff where he locked
dogs heads
in boxes so that the dogs couldn't
scratch their heads and then he put like
flesh-eating bugs in there i mean really
disgusting stuff that this guy has done
i would say one of the reasons the left
doesn't push against him is because it's
thought of as
sort of pro-democrat now because we have
a democrat president so let's just be
very clear imagine if donald trump was
president right now every single person
screaming for federal mandates would be
saying this is hitler this is nazi style
stuff that the president of the united
states orange hitler is forcing
companies to inject you with things this
is what the nazis did and this is why
you have to believe in something not
just know what you're against if you
only know what you're against you're
going to flip your opinion constantly on
everything right because you pick good
guys and bad guys and bad guys in charge
i hate bad guy good guys in charge i
love good guy even though good guy says
same thing the bad guy said but i like
good guys so i'm a good guy and
so none of these people are are taking
really honorable or honest positions um
fauci should step down it should be as
simple as that and actually to that
point i interviewed rand paul again we
just did a little uh mini interview
about 12 minutes this morning where we
talk more about what should happen to
fouchy we also get into some of the
inflation stuff and what's going on uh
we will put that up tomorrow hint hint
he does not like anthony fauci uh guys
before i move on let's talk about canva
you know making content is an essential
part of what my team and i do but we're
always trying to keep this show going
and we are always looking for new ways
to do it it hasn't always been a
seamless creative process from our
videos social media our website and our
community to merchandise business cards
and even my book cover our design skills
have been challenged in ways we could
have never imagined fortunately we have
recently found canva pro and now we can
design anything like a pro on any device
canva pro is a design platform that
empowers you to create and share
stunning content in just a few clicks
choose from thousands of templates that
are easy to customize or start from
scratch canva pro has endless premium
fonts photos videos and so much more
that add personality and edge to
whatever you're designing designing
together has never been easier sharing
editing and commenting in real time
canva pro helps you stay organized on
the same page and on top of team
projects no more misplaced files or
tedious back and forth plus you and four
teammates can unlock everything canva
pro has to offer for just 12.99 a month
and with canva pro's content planner
you'll save time planning creating and
posting social media content as well
pause scheduled posts and edit them at
any time design like a pro with canva
pro right now you can get 45 days free
with an extended trial when you use my
promo code just go to
canva.com
reuben
to oh did i just say that wrong i'm
sorry canva
c-a-n-v-a
dot me slash reuben not dot com dot me
canva dot me
slash reuben and now back to me okay
the dot me it's back baby
dana says hi dave although the osha
vaccine mandate has been suspended the
company i work for a large corporation
that sells soft drinks and rhymes with
metsy
has decided to implement the mandate for
all employees citing the osha rule so
i'm a single mom on the verge of losing
my job that i've held for nearly 13
years how do i fight back against this
okay so i
if partly referenced i mean you should
go to your hr people
and say to them you know this is no
longer a federal mandate and it's in the
courts now i get it the company is now
making a decision and i i you know i
have received so many emails from people
like you about this from doctors from
nurses literally from from janitors from
it people
i got an email from a from a like a 16
year old girl who's not being allowed to
do an experiment in her science class
because they won't even let her in like
crazy crazy nonsense this is where you
as an adult um
have to make a choice for yourself and
it's a horrific choice i suppose
but it's a horrific choice that millions
of people are having to make right now
so it's you know it's like okay should i
vaccinate my children even though
there's no evidence that i should and we
don't know exactly what this is going to
do and the very doctors at the fda who
approved it even said on video that they
don't know what it's going to do to kids
until they give it to kids and then
they'll figure it out like
i can't imagine what it would be like to
be a parent faced with that i would like
to believe that me as a parent uh would
say no i'm not letting my children be
vaccinated and if i have to move if i
have to whatever i have to do i'm not
going to allow this to be but i get it
people of all certain people don't want
to just pick up and go and you've got
roots places and you've got jobs and so
many things and financial worries and
all of these things and that's sort of
what they're preying on right they're
trying to make everything so
overwhelming you won't know what to do
so i think you should
think very seriously about about your
life like this is a very sort of jordan
peterson i would when i was on tour with
jordan he'd get certain questions like
this like something's happening at my
work or in my family that i'm really
against and what do i do and he would
always say well you know the easy thing
is like quit your job well okay you quit
your job but now you go and you stood up
for what you believe in but now you got
a freaking huge problem because you're
not making money you don't know how
you're going to pay your rent like you
have to really think through your life
right now um
and i don't know exactly what to do
about this i've been trying to think
about some way of doing some like mass
crowdfunding thing to make sure that
people who do fight back are not going
to be left out in the cold i if this is
seriously tough i would say at the very
minimum you should lodge a complaint
with uh mepsi your hr manager over at
mepsi and then i would say
find a lawyer like if you're willing to
fight if you're willing to take the risk
because otherwise what is it that you'll
work at a company that will force you to
be injected with things and what will be
next
what will be next that you'll have to
say yes to that goes against your
conscience and i know it sucks there's
no way of saying this properly because i
know it sucks and i'm not pretending
it's easy and i'm my own boss and the
chances that i force myself to do
something that i don't want to do is is
pretty slim right
so
so i'm not in that exact position um but
you got to stand up for what you believe
in like they are preying on the fact
that none of us will do that
and the more we have pushed back the
fact that this lawsuit now has suspended
it even even though mepsi is still doing
it
it shows if you fight back
that maybe just maybe that green
all-powerful oz guy is just some old you
know failed buffoon behind a curtain so
i wish you the best of luck and keep us
posted please fiona says is it called
stuffing or dressing it's stuffing i
called it stuffing before i still call
it stuffing what part of the country
usually calls it dressing can we get
some information on that i am from new
york and i live in california for now
and i've always called it stuffing sev
says will there ever be a time when we
return to a post-covet america
well it certainly will not be the
america that we all knew and loved there
is no going back to january 2020 when
orange man was president and the economy
was strong and all of that stuff like
i don't even mean to make this about
politics like whatever that old thing
that we knew about america was it that
is just not coming back it's just not
and i often say to these guys who are in
their 20s my uh my co-workers in the
room with me right now
it's like you guys are going to be the
last sort of young adults that will ever
remember that world you know if you're a
teenager growing up in all this you're
not going to have great memories of what
america used to be like and then of
course the media will always tell you
that america was always evil and then
that's how that will proliferate
throughout the system you know nobody
will remember what it was like like i'm
45 i remember when things were normal
and america was good and we stood up for
our values in the right way we're going
through a rough patch right now we have
a really horrible administration run by
a man with old person syndrome who's a
puppet for god knows what and we have a
media that is fueling this nonsense and
a tech world that is is injecting it
with steroids and it will be hard to
remember what that old good world was
but that old good world was good you
know actually i was coming back from
nashville and uh flying southwest i
don't want a brand but we did fly
southwest and uh i was watching um
father of the bride too
and it was on tnt i think
and
i was thinking as i was watching it i
was like this was it's first off it's
just a great simple movie if you haven't
seen father of the bride or father brad
too they're just great sort of perfect
quintessential steve martin movies and
they're they're just great but they're
just light and fun and it was like they
hearken back to an america that we kind
of had when it was like pretty good and
not everything was crazy political and
things could be light and fun and
everything else and
we just need to rebuild that
i have nothing better to do than save
the world do you i don't uh oh and i
have some info on stuffing versus
dressing while most new englanders and
the majority of west coasters refer to
the dish as stuffing about half of
texans and the majority of southerners
call it dressing
i did not know that
weird wild stuff pretty good that was
johnny carson that was johnny carson
impression did you get that got that
okay weird wild stuff i did not know
that jacob says we have been right about
pretty much everything for years but far
too many people still believe the
cathedral's narrative
this is of course
a shout out to michael malus the steele
dossier written house obvious
self-defense hunter biden laptop etc etc
how do we deal with these people do we
even bother
i address this one a lot i don't know i
don't know it's like the best we can do
is keep saying what we believe keep
showing people
oh you saw something on cnn well have
you seen this video clip or could you
maybe read this and a lot of times
they're going to tell you to go up
yourself they're going to tell you that
you're a right-wing maniac they're going
to tell you if you don't toe the party
line that's being pushed by mainstream
media you're some sort of conspiracy
theorist then you're an alex jones
obsessed q anon follower or something
like that
and you can either just give up or you
can keep trying in in little ways
that's why i love what prageru's done so
much because
they you know by creating these little
five-minute simple
simple animated videos on basic ideas
and getting incredible people
to to promote and host these videos i've
done a couple of them
you can translate
true good decent ideas and get them to
people in ways that maybe they wouldn't
get by just watching a cable news show
or even just watching a guy in a jacket
try to talk about politics or you know
just reading a full book about these
things
so there are ways to break through but
it can be really really tough you know
one line that i've that i've said many
times that i do think works is when
you're in one of these debates with
these people and they're just you know
they're going to keep calling you a
racist and they're going to keep saying
no no rittenhouse was a murderer and a
white supremacist even though the people
he shot was white and there's no
evidence he's a white supremacist or
they'll keep telling you that they're
coming to kids to raise this or brett
kavanaugh's a serial racist
it's like
all you have to say to them i think one
line that that somewhat can work
is hey you know what position
do you hold that is against woke
orthodoxy do you hold one position
that's against it and they'll have to
think
and now maybe they don't
or maybe you can find them on something
like do you agree with absolutely
everything that is woke do you believe
in eight-month abortions which pretty
much all democrats now believe like the
woke establishment certainly believes
like find something that might work for
them and if you say to them okay now i
found one thing i found one thing that
you disagree with these people about
what do you think they would do to you
and then you might get them to think
because they know that they destroy
people and one of the things that keeps
people in this constant uh self-hostage
situation which is a little bit sort of
like what i talked about with bill maher
is if you've run around and you've
called everybody that's against you
racist and home a homophobe and a bigot
and all of those things if you've done
this for years
well now you know what's going to happen
to you when you walk away i know it i
know it i don't think i was ever fully
even when i was a progressive i don't
think i was ever a fully like they're
all racist but i'm sure i was at some
level i really don't even remember
honestly um
but i think a lot of these people you
call people racist for so long then you
have your red pill moment and you go oh
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
the people i've been calling a racist
aren't really the racists and then you
start looking the other way and you go
wait a minute you guys who only want
black people to think one way you guys
only want gay people to think one way
maybe you're the bigots and the racists
and the prejudice people because you're
prejudge
that's a tough hostage situation to
negotiate yourself out of the best you
can do is give people room give people
room to get there and they will get
there and by the way a lot of times it
will just hit them in the head one way
or another because they will one day
they will one day have some experience
that will make it very obvious to them
that they're on the wrong side either
that or they can live life as a unit
clone it's as simple as that uh sean
says australia and austria are already
on board with not allowing the
unvaccinated from buying or selling and
or even leaving their homes will this
totalitarian will this totalitarian
mentality spread throughout the rest of
the globe
you know it's really crazy what's going
on in australia we've talked about that
a bunch and there's tons of videos that
you can see online but why does our
mainstream media never cover it does our
mainstream media not think it is
valuable to see thousands and thousands
of people protesting against vaccine
mandates and lockdowns in australia one
of our great allies do they not think
it's worth showing what's happening in
the netherlands or in france is it none
of that worth showing and why are they
not showing it to you do you think maybe
they're not showing it to you because
they don't want you to get any ideas and
realize that you have some power and
that you can stand up i think that might
have a little something to do with it uh
austria seems to be doing some crazy
stuff with lockdowns where now they're
maybe arresting people who aren't
vaccinated like really nuts stuff
i think it's going to continue to
continue to spread unfortunately
you cannot leave canada you literally
cannot leave canada
if you are unvaccinated
think about that
you can't leave the country not you
can't get in you cannot leave that's
kind of nazi stuff right if you think if
you said to all of the jews in 1938
germany hey you guys can get going now
they wouldn't have been thrilled but
eventually they didn't let them leave
right then they would put them on trains
and they would kill them okay so i know
everyone makes the nazi comparisons but
we are entering this weird territory why
wouldn't you let people leave your
country jordan peterson who i had on
last week mentioned that his father's
not vaccinated he doesn't like to be
pushed into things he's he's an elderly
guy i think he is in his early 80s but
he's made a decision for himself he is
now a prisoner in canada in a western
country in canada in in 2021 think about
that um so yes i think in certain
countries it's going to keep spreading
and i think america you know we've got a
spirit of freedom here
a wariness about government here
we've got guns here we've got
uh the chance to turn this around like
it all comes down on us like if america
goes down on this the western world is
done it's all on us
and it's all on the red states right now
and uh
that that gives you some work to do
right uh shh stack attack not shark
attack stack attack says gonna be less
serious today although i think you could
do a whole show to cover this tony
soprano dead or alive ooh i like this
one oh it's the last question too uh
tony soprano dead or alive so for those
of you that did not watch the sopranos
probably the greatest television show in
the history of tel oh yeah what's better
what are you nodding at what's better
than what house of house of cards uh
kids um
sopranos best television show did you
even watch sopranos you don't even watch
it
oh god sakes all right we're gonna have
to that's it now you're definitely not
getting avocado you're not getting
guacamole on the chipotle today um
sopranos okay so sopranos was a
spectacular spectacular show it ends and
again i guess if you want to pause this
or mute it because i'm about to tell you
the ending but if you haven't seen i
think i have a 10-year window on when
the show went off the air but it ends in
a spectacular fashion with tony and
carmela and the kids meeting at
holston's restaurant
it's just a little diner type restaurant
in bellevue new jersey i've actually
been there my friend lives a couple
blocks away i've sat at the very table i
know those of you that have seen the
ending know this exact table the exact
moment they sit at a table in holston's
and they're having this conversation and
they play on the jukebox they play uh
journey don't stop uh believing
and there's a moment where you see some
kind of shady people walk in and it's
like what's about to happen you know a
lot the jersey new york war has happened
a lot of the main characters die in
those last two episodes and it's like is
this the ending
for tony
and the show just goes to black
and they david chase who was the creator
of sopranos did this so brilliantly
because he le i love the ending i know a
lot of people
that sunday night on hbo a lot of people
were not happy because it wasn't
perfectly conclusive did tony soprano
just get shot is that why it went out to
black or is it or was it paranoia when
he was sort of looking at these shady
characters or why didn't you give us the
perfect answer but i absolutely loved it
i loved it it was just like
whatever you think happened happened so
what do i think happened
i think he probably got shot
and i know david chase has talked about
this and i'm actually not sure that
that's what he said um but like the idea
that like he was just sitting there in a
beautiful moment with his family they're
sitting at their little diner local
diner they're listening to a great
journey song and then it just ended
because a lot of bad stuff had happened
in those last episodes and there was a
guy who walked in it looked like he was
going to the bathroom but he kind of
glanced at tony and he looked like he
was maybe ready to do a hit just a great
great ending what a great show and i'm
docking your pay for telling me that you
haven't watched it have you watched it
you watch it alright thank you all right
guys part one of my interview with
candace owens shot on location at her
studio
in nashville at the daily wire studio in
nashville we did it a little bit off her
set it's a really fun interview and just
watching candace's uh you know climb
into stardom has just been spectacular
part one is on youtube and rumble right
now and the full episode is already up
at
reubenreport.locals.com and on blaze tv
and tomorrow we are live with harmy
dylan is it uh so we're not it's not a
panel tomorrow it's just oh fantastic so
tomorrow all of your questions about
kyle rittenhouse all of your questions
about osha and the mandates any other
legal stuff uh we're gonna knock out a
full episode with harmich he really is
is one of the people that is just
fighting on the front lines a great
brilliant lawyer fighting fighting and
you know what i'll try to get some of
your questions in
if you want which again you can submit
at rubincourt.locals.com
all right great day i'll tell you more
in about a month and have a good one see
ya